bienvenidos a la presentación de
triángulos 45 45 90 así que lo escribo
acá arriba
triángulos
45 45 90 o podríamos decir triángulos
rectángulos 40 y 55 90 pero eso sería
redundante porque sabemos que cualquier
triángulo que tenga un ángulo de 90 es
un triángulo rectángulo cierto así que
bueno y tal como tú puedes imaginar el
45 45 90 se refiere a los ángulos
internos del triángulo y porque son
estos triángulos tan especiales bueno
pues si viste la última presentación te
dio un pequeño teorema te dije que si
dos ángulos en la base de un triángulo
son iguales así que estos dos ángulos y
bueno de hecho podría yo dibujarlo de
distinta manera un triángulo orientado
así entonces si tenemos que estos dos
triángulos como puedes ver aquí no estoy
hablando de la base del triángulo si son
iguales entonces estos dos lados este
lado y este lado en este ejemplo y este
lado y este lado en este otro ejemplo
son dos iguales ahora lo interesante de
un triángulo 45 45 90 es que es un
triángulo rectángulo con esta propiedad
y bueno como sabemos que es el único
triángulo rectángulo que cumple esta
propiedad bueno pues podrías tú imaginar
un universo en el que yo te digo que
este es un triángulo rectángulo
ahora estoy aquí mide 90 y esta es la
hipotenusa es el lado opuesto al ángulo
de 90 grados y si yo te digo que estos
dos ángulos miden lo mismo este ángulo
mide lo mismo que este ángulo y los
llamamos x entonces este se llama xe
también se llama x porque son iguales y
bueno los ángulos internos de un
triángulo suman 180 así que tenemos x
mas x más 90 es igual a 180 entonces 2 x
más 90 es igual a 180 por lo tanto 12 x
es igual a 90 y tenemos entonces que x
es igual a 45 así que por lo tanto el
único triángulo rectángulo en el cual
los otros dos ángulos miden lo mismo es
un triángulo de 45 45 90 ahora bien qué
hay de interesante en un triángulo de 45
45 90 fuera de lo más allá de lo que yo
te vengo diciendo lo voy a dibujar otra
vez lo voy a dibujar así ya sabemos que
que este ángulo mide 90 y este ángulo de
45 grados también este otro ángulo es de
45 grados
basándonos en lo dicho hasta hasta ahora
sabemos que los lados que no comparten
los ángulos de 45 grados me refiero a
este lado es igual este a este lado es
igual a este lado y bueno si si lo
analizamos desde el punto de vista del
teorema de pitágoras
nos dice que los dos lados que no son la
hipotenusa son iguales así que bueno
esta es la hipotenusa y entonces
llamemos a uno de estos lados a este
lado llamémosle
y a este otro lado llamemos leve y
sabemos por el teorema de pitágoras que
la hipotenusa es así que el teorema de
pitágoras nos dice que al cuadrado más b
al cuadrado es igual a c al cuadrado
sabemos que es igual a b porque este es
un triángulo 45 45 90 así que podríamos
sustituir a por wwe por a da lo mismo
pero vamos a hacer ahora así que
entonces podríamos decir que ve al
cuadrado más b al cuadrado es igual a
sea al cuadrado y eso nos da 2 b al
cuadrado es igual a c al cuadrado
entonces b al cuadrado es igual a c al
cuadrado sobre 2 sea al cuadrado sobre 2
entonces b es igual a la raíz
o sea al cuadrado sobre 2 lo cual es
igual hace sobre raíz de 2 y ahora viene
aunque aunque esta es una presentación
sobre triángulos también te quiero dar
un poco de información sobre algo
llamado
racionalización de denominadores ahora
esto es perfectamente correcto hemos
llegado a que b donde b es igual aa
hemos llegado a que b es igual hace
sobre raíz de 2 pero hay algo más en
esta vida hay algo más porque resulta
que en matemáticas aunque yo jamás he
entendido porque sea este caso pero en
matemáticas no les gusta tener raíz de 2
en el denominador o bueno en general no
les gusta tener un número irracional en
el denominador y números irracionales
son números que no se pueden expresar
como fracciones poseen infinitas cifras
decimales que no se repiten ahora la
manera de deshacerse de un número
irracional en el denominador es
simplemente multiplicando vamos el
numerador y denominador por un mismo
número porque cuando multiplicas algo el
numerador y denominador por el mismo
número en este ejemplo supongamos bueno
aquí raíz de dos sobre raíz de dos eso
es uno ahora como tú puedes ver la razón
por la que yo hago esto es porque raíz
de 2 x raíz de 2 3 o cuánto es eso
cuánto dan exacto muy bien eso da 2
cierto así que
ahora el numerador en numeradores se
raíz de dos así que entonces acá arriba
es raíz de 2 en el numerador nótese que
se raíz de 2 sobre 2 es lo mismo que sé
sobre raíz de 2 y es muy importante esto
porque porque tal vez te topes con esto
en alguna tarea o peor aún en un examen
así un examen de opción múltiple donde
tú veas la respuesta con raíz de 2 abajo
o raíz de 3 o cualquier número
irracional que sea en el denominador y
quizás también veas a otra respuesta de
ser raíz de 2 sobre 2 entonces si el
examen es de opción múltiple que debes
hacer debe racionalizar y de esta manera
vamos a obtener se raíz de 2 sobre 2 y
esa será la respuesta correcta ahora
hasta este momento sabemos que ven es
igual a esto es igual a ser raíz de 2
sobre 2 así que lo escribo acá arriba
entonces sabemos que am es igual a b
donde b es igual a raíz de 2 sobre 2 por
c y tal vez sea bueno memorizar esto
aunque siempre puedes llegar a ellos y
si usas el teorema de pitágoras y
recuerdas que los lados que no son la
hipotenusa de un triángulo 45 45 90 son
iguales pero es bueno saberlo y por
ejemplo si te dan si te dan la
hipotenusa puedes averiguar la longitud
de uno de los lados el cual va a ser
igual al otro lado y de una manera muy
rápida de hecho o por ejemplo te dan la
amm te da la longitud de uno de los
lados entonces ya puedes averiguar
cuánto mide la hipotenusa así que
intentemos eso ahora voy a voy a borrar
todo esto así que acabamos de aprender
que quedan
es igual a b es igual a raíz de dos
sobre dos porsche y bueno y si yo te doy
un triángulo rectángulo así que y te
digo que aquí lo tenemos te digo que
este ángulo es 90 y que este ángulo mide
45 también digamos que este lado de acá
digamos que mide
18 entonces 8 yo quiero saber cuánto
mide este otro lado
entonces bueno en primer lugar hay que
averiguar cuál es la hipotenusa la
hipotenusa es el lado opuesto al ángulo
de 90 grados así que en realidad lo que
queremos averiguar es cuánto mide la
hipotenusa llamemos a este lado c
también sabemos que es un triángulo 45
45 90 cierto porque este ángulo mide 45
por lo tanto éste también mide 45 ya que
45 más 45 90 es igual a 180 entonces
esto es un triángulo 40 y 55 90 y
conocemos uno de sus lados el cual puede
ser ahora bien 8
a raíz de dos sobre dos porsche y
queremos saber cuánto mide sen entonces
si multiplicamos ambos lados de la
ecuación por el inverso de raíz de dos
sobre dos sería 2 sobre raíz de 2 y 2
sobre raíz de 2 porque bueno ahora se
van a cancelar el raíz de dos sobre raíz
de 2 este se cancela con este y el 2 se
cancela con el 2 entonces tenemos que 2
por 8 es 16
16 sobre raíz de 2 y esto es muy
correcto porque como te lo mencioné
antes como te acabo de mostrar a las
personas no les gustan los radicales en
el denominador así que podríamos decir
que se es igual a 16 sobre raíz de dos
por raíz de dos sobre raíz de dos lo
cual es igual a 16 raíz de 2 sobre 2
y lo cual es igual esto es igual a 8
raíz de 28 raíz de 2 entonces en este
ejemplo es igual a 8 raíz de 2 y sabemos
que como este este es un triángulo
cuenta de 55 90 también este lado mide 8
ajá así que bueno espero que hayas
entendido todo lo que todo lo que dije
en este vídeo en el próximo vídeo te voy
a mostrar diferente un diferente tipo de
triángulo quizás también inicie con
algunos ejemplos de este tipo así que
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo bain